everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem target sum we're given
an array of integers called nums and
we're also given a single integer called
target and basically for every single
number in the array nums we can either
choose to add that number or subtract
that number and we must do that for
every single number we have to either
choose to add it or subtract it and then
using that we will have some
total or some sum at the end of our
you know computation and basically we
want to know does that computation that
sum that we have that total is it equal
to the target value that we were given
at the beginning right and not only that
but we want to count the number of ways
that we can get a sum from this array
nums that will equal this target value
and then we want to return how many ways
we were able to do that so in this
example you can see we're given an array
numbers of five consecutive ones and a
target value of three and you can see
all the different ways that we can sum
up to that total value of three there
are five different ways to do that right
you can see the first one if we subtract
the first one add the next one add the
next one add the next one and add the
next one we're able to get to three
right basically four positive and one
negative that will give us a sum of
three you can see that the next example
the next way that we were able to do
that basically we subtracted the second
one added the first and then added the
next three the main thing though to note
is that the order that you do these does
matter so if we can change the order of
the plus and minus symbols you know that
counts as a different way that we are
able to total up to the target right so
basically we're we're counting
permutations so this can be a complex
problem if you're not familiar with it
so let's start off with the brute force
solution which is going to be 2 to the
power of n and then let's see how we can
actually optimize that into a more
efficient solution so suppose we're
given that same example that we just
talked about target of three and five
ones in the input remember for every
single one of the values we have a
choice right we can either add it or
subtract it right and the best way to
visualize this for me is always using a
decision tree right so if we want to
know all possible ways we could you know
enumerate this and all possible totals
we could get from this array a decision
tree is the most helpful initially we
start at the index right we're keeping
track of what index we're at right
initially we're going to be at the
zeroth index we're going to keep moving
on and on as we make choices right to
the second third fourth index until we
of course reach the end of the array
another thing we're going to be keeping
track of what is our total so far right
of course we want to know what our total
is so far because by the time we reach
the end of the array we want to know is
our total equal to the target value or
not so using this pair of values as our
parameter to our recursive function
we'll get a decision tree that looks
something like this initially we'll be
at zero zero right index zero and our
total will initially be set to zero we
can make a choice right we're at this
one over here right at the top left we
can either make a choice to add that one
right plus one or
minus one if we add the one then our
index is going to be at 1 because we're
going to move to the next position right
we're going to be at this position now
which is at index 1. and our total write
the second value we're keeping track of
is also going to be 1 because we added a
1. now if we did the opposite choice we
would still end up at index 1 but our
total would be negative one right that's
our second value over here and this
decision tree is actually going to be
pretty simple for us because all of the
values in the input are one so basically
every single decision is going to look
exactly like this one let me just kind
of quickly draw it out to give you an
idea okay so we kind of ran out of room
so i won't draw the entire tree but just
to show you a path a single path that
will lead us to the target so initially
we start at the the first spot right we
add the first one right so this is a
positive right we're at one so far then
we go down this path where we said we
minus one right then our total is at
zero so minus one then we add one again
we're at index three total of one so
plus one here then we add another one
we're at index four total of two
and then we add a last one right the
fifth one we add this as well that
leaves our total exactly at three which
is good and it puts us at index five
well index zero is here one here two
here three four five is exactly out of
bounds so as soon as we go out of bounds
we're done right we've reached our base
case now we want to know is our total so
far which right now happens to be three
is it equal to the target yes it's
exactly equal to the target so now we're
done we found a single way that we could
reach the target value right of course
there's going to be other dis there
other paths in our decision tree that
also lead to the result but there's also
going to be some paths that may be sum
up to you know possibly one right if we
subtract two of them and then add three
of them that'll leave us with a positive
one which is not equal to our target so
in that case we won't count that but
ultimately we're going to count how many
different paths were able to lead us to
that target value now this is the brute
force of course this tree could have a
height of n and we obviously have two
branches each time uh right two
different paths for every single node so
that will put the time complexity at two
to the power of n how can we optimize
this well the trick is going to be in
the parameters that we're passing into
our recursive function right the index
which we're maintaining and the total
sum that we have as well using these we
can actually optimize this solution so
we can use the idea of caching to
optimize this problem as with most
dynamic programming problems so take a
look at the parameters we have the index
which we're passing in and the total now
how many possible values could we pass
in for the index value of course
you know the size of nums right so
that's how many would n is how many
possibilities we could have for this
index how many different possible values
could we pass in for the total that's
definitely a little bit harder to
determine and the simple solution to
that is what's the the maximum total
that we could have from this array of
nums in this case just add up all the
nums it's 5 right 5 is the biggest
number we could pass in for total and
since 5 is the biggest number we could
possibly also you know if we subtract
every value we could get you know
passing a negative 5 here right and
potentially every value in between
positive five and negative five not
necessarily though but possibly that's
the big idea here right since we're
going for worst case time complexity
which is big o time complexity we have
to think about the worst case and
possibly we could pass in every value
between positive five and negative five
so overall uh the way to think about how
many different values we could pass in
for the total is basically the total sum
of the nums array right and let's just
call that t for simplicity so
t
uh n times t where t is the total number
of values we could pass in or rather the
sum of the entire array that's going to
be the overall time complexity if we
perform caching using this pair of
values so it's pretty easy to implement
caching once you have coded up the
recursive solution so we can now jump
into the code okay so now let's write
the code it's actually not too bad so
remember we are going to be using a
cache i'm going to call that dp it's
just going to be a hash map in this case
and we're going to be mapping a pair of
values which is the index and
the total so far we're going to be
mapping this pair of values to the
number of ways that we can actually get
to the target value if we start at this
index with this particular total value
now we can actually write out our
recursive function i'm just going to
call it backtracking and i'm going to
define it in
this
function let's just call it backtrack
i'm going to define it nested inside of
this outer function so that we don't
have to pass in every parameter like dp
like nums and target into this function
we only have to pass an index and the
current total so far not too bad now
remember
i always like to start out with our base
case what's our base case is it it's if
we reach the end of the array so if i is
equal to length of nums let me remain
rename index to i just to keep things a
little bit shorter so if we've reached
the end of the array then what are we
going to do well we want to return 1 if
our total is equal to the target value
right if this is true then we can return
1. if it's not true then we have to
return 0 meaning that this is not a way
to reach the target value so in python
it's pretty easy to do that but you can
use a ternary operator in your language
of choice and the other base case is
going to be if we've already seen this
before we've already seen this pair of
index total before then that means it
must exist in our cache because that's
what we're going to be doing as we
compute these we're going to be caching
them so if it exists in our cache well
which we can check like this if it's in
dp then we can just return
dp at index i and this total value if
either of those base cases does not
evaluate to true then we get to the fun
part the recursive part which is
actually going to be pretty easy because
we don't need any loops or anything like
that we can just you know determine the
answer for this uh pair of values this
index total and how are we going to do
that we're going to of course call our
recursive function backtrack and
remember we really had two choices that
we could make uh one choice was to add
the value at index i right if we do that
then the or the next index we're going
to be passing is just going to be i plus
1 right we're going to be doing that no
matter what regardless of whether we add
or subtract the value but this for the
second parameter for the total parameter
we're going to pass in the current total
plus nums of i that's if we're adding
this now we could do the exact same
thing if we're subtracting it so let's
do that on the next line i'm going to do
a plus sign because then when we go to
the next line we want to put the
opposite instead of adding this we're
going to be subtracting nums of i the
index though stays the same i plus 1. so
if we take these two function calls add
the results together that will tell us
how many possible ways starting at index
i and with this total that we could sum
up to the target value right if we add
these together then we can store them in
our cache and then we can just return
the result turn dp of index i
and total so then we're good to go we
have a completed our recursive function
it really is that simple you just have
to worry about the base cases and the
recursive case which in our case was
simple it's just two decisions pretty
simple then we of course have to
remember to actually call our
backtracking function i always forget
that so we're going to start at index
equals 0 and our total initially is also
going to be zero
then we can return the result of this
function in our outer function and then
we're done right this is the answer they
were looking for we returned it let's
run it to make sure that the code works
and as you can see on the left yes it
does work and it's pretty efficient so i
really hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot consider
checking out my patreon where you can
further support the channel if you'd
like and hopefully i'll see you pretty
soon thanks for watching